ja gut zu mir leid ich bin halt kritisch
ich bin ja mittlerweile auch schon der
kragen der tester kennst du stiftung
warentest habe ich vor 17 jahren
gegründet was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ich
habe keine lust aufzustellen deswegen
setzt sich noch wieso muss ich dann
steht das weiß ich du hast sicher von
der leine hingestellt jawohl wir das
immer so machen
ach so kann man dann stelle ich mich
auch mal kurz welche wundert euch nicht
gerne sagt sampl gemacht ich zeige euch
mal kurz wie wir das gemacht haben und
zwar von einem wechselbad die restlichen
raten sollen boxen verwendet die
eigentlich schon als müll liegen
ich muss eigentlich gar nicht viel
erzählen
ihr seht ja schon worum es geht und zwar
habe ich wieder eure kommentare
rausgesucht habe jetzt läuft der ganze
judo zwischen runter ich habe auf jeden
fall wieder durch die kommentare des
gold und habe gesehen ihr habt woche auf
alle sorten von joghurt mit der ecke
alle ritter sport sorten alle jungen die
um sorten das sind diese nudeln und ich
habe mich heute erstmal für joghurt mit
der ecke sorten entschieden weil das
krasse war die waren im angebot ein
joghurt 29 cent und die ritter sport
schokolade wie ich auch mit gekauft habt
20 sorten oder so waren auch im angebot
59 cent und werther sofort zugeschlagen
dreimal dürft ihr raten für alle wenigen
die dieses format noch nicht kennen wir
probieren alle sorten haben am ende
einmal die beste sorte die schlechteste
sorte meines geschmacks nach und ihr
könnt das dann gerne nachkaufen und mir
bei instagram bestätigen ob das stimmt
oder nicht nur ja nicht schlecht oder
und was auch nicht schlecht für schritt
auf jeden fall weitere produkte die ich
noch testen in die kommentare
ich stelle ihnen mal so auf und dann
machen wir weiße dieser bleibt bestehen
wieso also wir fangen an joghurt mit der
ecke mascarpone mango was ist das denn
ja ich bin extrem gespannt deshalb
wirklich so machen wo drin auch noch
ganz wichtig ist zu sagen ich kenne
keinen einzigen dieser joghurts ich habe
früher warum guckst du so nicht mal so
hier gings kirche waren der lohn
ich habe früher immer diesen gegessen da
waren smarties bei den kannte ich weiß
nicht ob das jungen mit der ecke war
aber sonst war ich nie so großer fan
davon
doch und in eine nicht kennen dann habe
ich nicht gekauft weil das wäre sonst
langweilig klappt das schon mal richtig
gut hier die ecke klagt ja richtig wo er
ist ein löffel ja es muss man aber sieht
eigentlich aus wie karamell lerne ich
mal gespannt sind die kinder weiß wenn
ich ne gilt also für 29 cent kann man
jetzt nicht meckern
die mango ist total aufgeweicht leiste
drei von zehn
tut mir leid hatte echt nicht so gut
geschmeckt als nächstes haben wir
joghurt mit der ecke showstars den kenne
ich ähnlich mit kugel mir hast du noch
früher oder da waren so kugel drin
einfach stehen habe ich nämlich immer
gegessen
genau jetzt wird wieder ein und der kann
mich noch gut klappen so haben wir nicht
früher mal geknackt so glauben nur in
der werbung ja hier haben wir einen mix
aus heller schokolade dunkler schokolade
und ganz dunkler schokolade wenn ich mal
gespannt wie schmeckt wahrscheinlich mir
denke es lag also auf jeden fall 1000
mal besser als der aber es ist auch
nicht so krass dass ich sage puh hefte
ich weiß noch als wir die müllermilch
getestet haben alter da waren die ersten
drei alben und sehen das hier ist ja
zone lebte weitesten von 10 also die
werden hier jetzt aber nach punkten
aufgereiht als nächstes haben wir mit
sleep rostet haselnuss also das sind
glaube ich neue sorten weiß nicht ob man
die verpackung hat so holz und im
holzdesign jetzt klappt schon wieder
nicht was ist das denn für'n verstärkt
obwohl sich obwohl es heißt genau was
sie da eigentlich schon ganz werke aus
ich merke ziemlich cool und lustig denn
ich oder der junge ist auch anders sein
hier und cremiger joghurt steht da ja ja
dass das merkt man direkt mir gefällt
mir gar nicht dass also hier geht es ja
um den geschmack
hier geht es nicht um ein gesundes essen
deswegen kriegt er von mir fünf von zehn
punkte mehr ist da nicht drin
schmeckt halt nicht das schmeckt so wie
wir nicht früher mir gedacht habe okay
du bist jetzt jeden morgen kontext ganz
schön ungesund gestellt jetzt am
nächsten morgen auf missy um dann hast
du das einen tag so gegessen und am
nächsten tag hast du dir gesagt was auch
gereicht ich will wieder komplex weil ja
einfach keiner ist und so also dass mac
zu gesund okay was haben als nächstes
mit der ecke crispy quatsch
so ähnlich mit dem schoko stars und
jetzt klappt aber ja
so soll das sich an alle schon ziemlich
gleich aus jetzt die letzten 36 löcher
geil
und wieso ist es lecker erstmal der
jugend an sie ist gut diese crispy krank
und sehr ist nichts und schmecken so
ganz vielleicht noch karamell dem würde
ich am liebsten direkt auf 919 punkte
muss man sagen heftig leider keine zehn
von zehn aber ich bin zu man richtig
dass erhält bei dem nicht ganz geschafft
was ist das ist das beim service sektor
pistazie da habe ich mich nur gefragt
wie sieht denn hier diese dieser der aus
dem aller züge presse ist grün
ich denke dass moussavi joghurt ist grün
so interessant dass hier müssten so
warte mal schlicht mal ran
das ist wie wenn du in einem guten
restaurant oder in einem guten kaffee im
café bestellst kriegst du immer so einen
kleinen keks dazu das sind diese dinge
einen kleinen eigentlich geil
brandmelder ich hoffe der joghurt
schmeckt also wer sich das so ausgedacht
hat wie sagt man jetzt neuerdings ist ja
schon zehn konzern ist natürlich hier
die frage weil sie etwas ganz neues
mit pistazien joghurt anscheinend krieg
zu zehn von zehn muss ich jetzt einfach
außen heftig also das ist wirklich
lecker wenn er das noch nicht probiert
habe vertrauter mal auf meinen rat kauft
euch das und schreibt mir eure meinung
über instagram alex sowas haben wir
selbst schuld nicht alter jetzt hat man
mal von den allen wer spricht mich am
meisten an von denen ja was soll man da
noch muss man einmal rum kommentiert das
ad hoc barry schoko banane erdbeere
stracciatella butterkekse knuspert
kuchen und kirche vanille und das ist
der joghurt mit der ecke des modells
schüler des monats du hast du mal ja
klar immer gab es gar nicht gab es bei
euch in der grundschule gab es sterne
systeme wäre immer etwas gutes gemacht
rief scheiße also ich freue mich am
meisten auf diese mitleid und den hier
des monats lasst uns in der wende machen
joghurt mit der ecke butterkeks alter
das hört sich auch gut an es gibt auch
nichts was es nicht gibt bleibt doch die
wirkung ich hab doch die partnerschaft
zeigt ich habe mich darauf hier also man
muss auch sagen es gibt ja auch nichts
was es nicht gibt so gefühlt sind das
denn jetzt butterkekse da hätte man auch
ein bisschen mehr rein tun können oder
ostern ist schon wieder irgendwie ein
bisschen andere junge geschmack
überzeugt mich erst nicht so wie die
letzten beiden
aber rechts von mir acht von zehn das
ist irgendwie manchmal richtig schwierig
da ein unterschied zu erkennen weil der
schmeckt jetzt zum beispiel ziemlich
ähnlich wie dieser hier
wenn wir den wir sieben punkte geben
haben also 18 ist hier auf jeden fall
angebracht so nochmal jemand weiter als
nächstes jung und der ecke erdbeer
stracciatella was hinter auch lecker
sein also schon gefilmt oder weil ich
auch mal danke lena projekt
doch ich glaube den kenne ich den gibt
es auch schon länger oder ganze ewigkeit
denn jetzt ewigkeiten los und ich habe
auch gehört der klagt auch schon seit
ewigkeiten mit ansage ich kann mich aber
nicht mehr richtig an den geschmack
erinnern ich glaube da war ich noch zu
klein für so ist hat noch was anderes
jetzt von dem her ist das ja ähnlich wie
der erste
schmeckt halt noch nicht so schlecht
wieder erster aber vielleicht mag es
auch einfach nur eben als manko für juli
sowas würde ich in der schule hören von
dir ein kommentar ist auch nicht so
leicht wie letzten krieg auf 818 punkte
also ich bin immer noch jeweiligen
persönlichen dingen aber hat es jetzt
mehr acht als butterkekse sie mehr acht
gleich 8 wir haben ja nicht mehr oder
weniger ich habe mich mal gefragt kann
ich auch ja meine persönliche meinung
welchen fand ich so besser von den
beiden beide gleich sonst hätte ich ja
nicht gesagt kommt ideen hier ein
bisschen besser okay wir haben damit er
hier den mit erdbeer habe ich daher so
positioniert damit du auch zufrieden ist
so als nächstes
haben wir mit der ecke müsli schoko
banane und das hier war ein müsli
haselnuss muss ich das jetzt auch noch
probieren schmeckt wahrscheinlich
genauso gesund 15
ich habe irgendwie klappt nicht ich
finde ich richtiger profi oder die
tiefen die banane davon aus dass muss
ehrlich sagen ich habe die banane drin
noch nicht identifizieren nicht
getroffen und immer ein stückchen ich
probier's mal ohne worte 2010 ist keine
1 von 10
aber zwei von zehn ohne worte ja heute
gehen wir aber hart ins gericht ja gut
zu mir leid ich bin halt kritisch ich
bin ja mittlerweile auch schon der
fahrer tester gänze stiftung warentest
habe ich vor 17 jahren gegründet müssen
nicht alex gütesiegel einfach machen ja
wenn auch zum guss von stiftung
warentest getestet oder denke schon ja
schließlich etwas schlechtes und zwar
stetig von wieder am höchsten wie
gelaufen
das ist jetzt mein job berliner genau
richtig gut er kann vielleicht ist das
ein bisschen besser wegen diesem leid
schock aber ich will jetzt auch nicht zu
viel versprechen
das aber steht inhalt trainieren wie in
meinem kopf ist jetzt auf jeden fall der
beste musik von uns bei ausländischen
vorne ran
dann wurde es geht also standard 7 von
10 jähriges gut man hat hier nämlich auf
der einen seite immer noch dieses
gesunde diesen gesunden beigeschmack
dieser beigeschmack ergänzt sich
allerdings durch dieses workshops zu
einem leicht süßen aroma und dieser
mittelweg der dazwischen entsteht der
wird als ein von mir betrachtet leckerer
geschmack identifiziert joghurt mit der
ecke kirche wandel aber wir müssen die
gleiche noch auf messen also ich schaue
auf jeden fall 4
sollte jemand noch holen noch einladende
kirche vanilla das hört sich für mich
auch geil an
wir machen den mal auch also um den
total erkennen zu sehen hab echt wir
haben jetzt wieder ein junge das ist
richtiger vanille junge sieht zumindest
so aus und jetzt klagt wahrscheinlich
wieder nicht so hier ein achter sind ja
schon drin meint dass in echte kirschen
oder irgendwelche fällt mit kirschen
essen
hab ich muss kurz nach dem ich gehe ich
finde das ein richtiger nachtisch und
den kanzler als nachtisch wissen und die
anderen ja so als vorspiel sei aber
nicht vom thema abschweifen also uri
guten geschmack den oder hast würde ich
nicht anschließen
allerdings empfehle ich dir auch mal
dinge zu probieren weil das ist eine 10
von 10
und die sind hier würde ich dann auch er
bei einer neun von zehn einsortieren
jetzt bin ich aber mal gespannt der
weist nämlich zum schluss den joghurt
des monats mit plus bei kugeln bei denen
es auch schon weihnachten meister da
zieht man hier oben er liegt schon
schnee oder sieht wieder aus wie so ein
weiße schokolade dunkler schokolade mit
joghurt was ich aber eben noch meinte so
ein habe ich früher immer gegessen also
mittendrin weißt du das waren auch so
vanille schoko kugeln und dann halt
einfach ganz normaler joghurt daneben
und ich denke immer wenn das herz an die
kugeln die ich meinte waren ein bisschen
kleiner als diese hier kannst du die
nicht noch diese ganz klar ja genau
und die sind hier ist ein bisschen
größer war also ich muss sagen ich hätte
da jetzt ein bisschen mehr erwartet chou
am geschmack der junge das ein bisschen
anders
was ist das ich glaube ich habe mich da
fand das ganz normaler joghurt ja nichts
besonderes
acht von zehn ich macbooks kann man gut
essen aber gewonnen hat auf jeden fall
hier joghurt mit der ecke venezia typ
pistazien joghurt und amaretto nie
deutet den empfehle ich euch mal
probiert den großen respekt an den
macher dieses joghurt so viel bis
hierhin
ich hoffe ihr konntet gut folgen und
probiert das mal wie gesagt schicken bei
instagram foto oder als ich alex wie das
meiste sich machtlos morgen 19 wieder
aber ihr den kanal aktiviert die glocke
und gibt's übrigens welchen wir gut in
den einheiten schon gut so
reingeschnuppert nicht probieren
das stimmt doch gar nicht